This episode is brought to you by curiosity stream,
a subscription streaming service that offers over 2000 documentaries and
non-fiction titles unlimited access starting at just two 99 a month and 30 days
for free. If you sign up through the link below and use the channel code,
biographics more on them.
Yeah, it was a question for you.
What would you call a man who spends all day as equally Brown nosing his
superiors as he does bullying of those below him?
The man who swears like a sailor groups, his secretaries,
and is so obsessed with toilet humor that he considers it.
The height of hilarity to make employees watch him urinate.
What'd you call him crude boarish and abuse up,
or what'd you call him a great man, a reformist hero.
When talking about the 36th presidents they own, sir is, well,
all of those things born in Texas in 1908,
Lyndon B Johnson was a strange and complex man elevated to the presidency.
Following John F Kennedy's assassination.
Johnson was notorious for treating those around him like trash mere decoration
to his relentless pursuit of power.
He bullied staffers exposed himself to colleagues and emotionally abused
everyone. Yet.
He was also the president who forced through the civil rights and voting rights
act and did segregation and reinforce HIZ millions of nonwhite Americans,
both an ogre and a Saint, a monster, and a man.
This is the fascinating tale of Lyndon Johnson.
America's most complicated. President.
[Inaudible].
And Lyndon Baines Johnson was born on the 27th of August, 1908.
There was almost no bigger backwater of in Texas Hill country.
The first of five children,
Johns and grew up in a house with no electricity in a world in which indoor
plumbing was probably slang for genitalia.
But while the family lived in circumstances, best described as humble,
they weren't nobody's Johnson's father Sam Eley Johnson Jr.
Was a one-time member of the state house of representatives among his ancestors.
Sam could count both Texas revolutionaries and Confederate soldiers,
but Sam was also a dreamer with little head for business.
By the time Johnson was born downtown already sent the family into depths with
cotton market speculation.
The indignity of being from an educated family on hard times seems to have
seeped its way into Johnson's soul for his entire life.
The 36th presidents would be ultimately morose and prickly about what
happened to his daddy.
Still the family's fortunes recovered enough that in 1913,
Sam was able to move into a bigger house in Johnson city,
but this was only an improvement in Texas Hill country terms Johnson still had
to ride a mule three miles to his one room school, each date, yes,
even at this early age, the boy was getting a taste for politics. In 1918,
Sam decided to run for his old seat in the Texas house of representatives.
He brought his boy along on the campaign aged only 10 Johnson got his first at
the rough and tumble world of electoral politics. When his daddy won,
it made a big impact and there's a wall after the boy told his classmates,
you know,
someday I'm going to be president of the United States by the early 1920s.
The now teenage Johnson was sitting in on legislative sessions watching Sam
work.
Unfortunately the early twenties was also when the U S plunged into its sharpest
recession. Yet Sam who reinvested in cotton, lost everything.
Again,
Johnson would like to say that he decided then and there that I was not going to
be the victim of a system,
which would allow the price of a commodity like cotton to drop and destroy the
homes of people like my own family. However,
he did very little to actually escape the system. In 1924,
Johnson graduated as president of a six pupil class and applied to Southwest
Texas state teacher's college only to be rejected and see his life grind to a
miserable Holt. By now, the boy had grown into a huge man of six foot,
three inches. He weighed 200 pounds.
So when he responded to his college rejection,
by turning to drinking and fighting a better believe that he'd caused a ruckus
arrested after a brutal Johnson left Texas in business,
buying a car with five friends and heading to California,
but he felt a little better in the sunshine state where he failed to make any
friends. He was just too set and that people were looking down on him.
Not physically. That would have been difficult, especially for,
as rural backgrounds is vulgar ways for the rest of his life.
Johnson would never escape his insecurities about who he was and where he came
from. After three aimless years, Johnson reapplied for college in 1927.
This time he was accepted and began studying to be a teacher.
As part of his training,
he was assigned to a Mexican-American school in Cotulla Texas.
What he saw there would shake the bits of John's to his core.
The school was a dump. The children lived in poverty. So grinding,
it made Johnson's own upbringing seem positively luxurious.
It wasn't long after that, that Johnson made a crucial decision,
forget teaching. He was going to go into politics,
31 Sam's political friend.
Richard Kleberg announced that he would run for Congress Johnson already looking
for ways out of the teaching Wells quit to help with the campaign.
This move kickstarted his career after Kleberg one Texas's 14th congressional
district. He invited Johnson to accompany him to Washington, DC Johnson.
Didn't so much grass, but this opportunity,
as he did pull it into a gigantic bag and wrestle it to the ground for the
next two years,
Johnson spent every waking moment learning the ropes on Capitol Hill.
The sense of power seems to have intoxicated him.
He barely slept instead digging deep into congressional protocol and furiously
sucking up to anyone and everyone. This included fellow Texan,
Sam radon,
while there was their shed origin that drew Johnson and Rayburn together,
it was Ray-Ban's connections to the establishment that kept the young man
hanging on his every word in no time at all,
this friendship would pay Johnson dividends,
but not before it made some major changes to his private life.
When Johnson announced in 1934, that he was going to marry Claudia altar Taylor,
better known by her childhood nickname, Ladybird,
it must have caused a few raised eyebrows.
Johnson was notorious for having an overactive sex drive.
How his friends must have wondered. Was Johnson going to keep,
as Johnson talked away from marriage,
the simple answer was that he wasn't throughout his married life.
Johnson would cheat on lady bird with a frequency as regular as it was
depressing. Not the Johnson's bad behavior did any damage to his career.
Under Sam Rayburn's wing Johnson began to shine when FDRs new deal set up a
national youth administration in every state to provide jobs and educate the
young, right then ensured his protege became the Texas direct app,
but don't do thinking Johnson's only skill was his commitment to licking
everything,
but that crossed his path as Texas national youth administration director.
Jonathan did a Sterling job for two years.
He puts in heart attack inducing hours to make sure that his program
over-performed ever since he had witnessed real poverty in the Katurah school,
Johnson had felt a kinship with America's dispossessed.
He may have been a power hungry home dog,
but he was also one that wanted to help by February,
1937 Johnson's work had made him famous in Texas.
So when a special election was held in his home district, Johnson was a shoo-in.
He convinced lady bird to sing $10,000 of her own inheritance into his campaign,
which is about $180,000 in today's money.
And he promoted himself as a supporter of the new deal.
The election was a cakewalk that year, age,
just 28 Johnson returned to the house, no longer an aide, but a representative.
One of his first victories was finally bringing electricity to Texas Hill
country until the day he died,
Johnson would insist that that was his greatest achievements, but Johnson,
wasn't happy to stop at a seat in the house in 1941,
Texas Senator Maurice shepherd and his replacement. Andrew Jackson, Houston,
both obligingly died. Leaving. See it wide open Johnson declared had run for it,
certain that he was going to win. But this time he was going to meet his match.
W Lee Pappy O'Daniel was Texas as populist governor and a
stunning weasel.
When Johnson dabbled in voter fraud during the primary happy to responded by
pulling off fraudulent voting on a breathtaking scale, unable to compete.
Johnson was forced to watch in horror.
As the Senate seat he felt was his birthright just slipped through his fingers.
In the aftermath of his defeat.
Johnson pulled some strings and had himself made a Lieutenant commander in the
Navy. Maybe he wanted to bolster his public image.
Maybe he just wanted to shake off the bitter taste of losing. Unfortunately,
that Navy was bound to be dragged into the biggest war in history.
But before we get into that, well,
I want to take a quick moment to tell you about today's sponsor.
Curiosity stream.
Curiosity stream is a subscription streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and non-fiction titles from some of the world's best filmmakers,
including exclusive originals. Now, if you're enjoying this one,
then why not try out curiosity stream for free and check out their docu-series
called American icons.
This has some fantastic short documentaries and some of America's most notable
historic people. So if you're enjoying this video,
I think that's something you really shouldn't miss.
And something you can watch for free CuriosityStream is available on many
platforms as a web app, Roku, Android, X-Box one smart TVs, IRS Chrome costs.
The list just goes on. If you've got a device,
you're probably going to be able to watch curiosity stream on it is also
available worldwide.
So none of that geo restriction nonsense that you sometimes run into with
streaming platforms,
you can get unlimited access starting at just two 99 a month. And for you guys,
the first 30 days are completely free. If you sign up at curiosity,
stream.com forward slash biographics and use the special promo code
biographics during the signup process, that is a great way to support this show.
It's a great way to keep me making more videos.
And I just think curiosity streams a great fit for videos like this. I mean,
we make educational content. They make educational content great fits,
and let's get back to today's video.
[Inaudible].
The day he died,
Lyndon Johnson would proudly wear his silver stop awarded in 1942.
It showed that it's served under hostile fire.
A distinction marked him out from most of his fellow congressmen.
What it didn't show was that it only ever flown a single mission while hundreds
of thousands of others were sent off to die in the waters of the Pacific
representative, Johnson was able to earn his medal and then be all like, Oh,
that was fun. Bye guys,
metals assigned DOR was good for Johnson in other ways as well.
He shrewdly invested in new war technologies, turning a substantial profits.
By the time he returned to Congress, he was wealthy and he was decorated,
but he was also precarious.
And the aftermath of the war Johnson ran for his sixth house term.
Although we won, he was shaken up by the way,
his opponents painted him as a war profiteer. Who'd got rich while others died.
If his career was going to continue, it needed to escape the house fast.
Luckily, an opportunity. It was bound to present itself in the summer of 1948.
One of Texas's, two Senate seats, again, fell empty.
The front runner for it was Coke Stevenson and a man. So beloved in Texas,
that he was literally known as Mr. Texas,
but Johnson had learned his lesson from his earlier failed Senate bit.
This don't him. He would get that seat no matter what to say.
Johnson bleed dirty would be an insult to debt. He engaged in voter fraud.
So massive. It could probably be seen from space.
There's even a rumor that he tried to paint Stevens. And as someone,
a little too friendly with his pet pics,
but it was the voter fraud that carried the day three extremely suspicious
tallies.
At the last minute swung the race Johnson won by 87 votes out of nearly a
million cost. He also won himself the ironic nickname, landslide, Lyndon,
but what did Johnson care?
It set his sights on a Senate seat and he'd won it nor was he content to
stop that. And no time at all, Lyndon Johnson was going to rise so fast.
Even Lyndon Johnson would be surprised and things got rolling in 1950
that year, the Republicans toppled,
many of the Democrat old guard in the Senate with a senior's gone Johnson was
able to get promoted to democratic whip.
This meant he was perfectly poised when the 1952 election felt even more senior
Democrats in the aftermath, the Democrats made Lyndon Johnson minority leader.
The upshots when the Democrats took the sentence in 1954,
Johnson aged only 46 automatically became majority leader.
The youngest person to hold the role in history.
But almost as soon as he reached the top of the Senate,
Johnson almost lost everything in mid 1955,
the chronic smoker suffered a heart attack. So massive.
It was described as the worst man could have and still live.
And the Optum health Johnson was confined to his house for months where he fell
into a deep depression.
Those who knew him say that he spent those black months wondering what would
have happened if it died, what is a bittery would have said?
And he came to a terrifying conclusion. It would say,
here's a man who wants to power for power's sake and to got what he wanted.
He did nothing for anyone else. And as soon, no one will remember him.
When Johnson finally returned to work, he was a changed man. He quit smoking,
started trying to lose weight,
but the changes were more than superficial from that long Johnson would no
longer pursue power merely for power sake.
It would use it to change the way people saw him to change the way that they
would remember him in doing so. It would also change history.
Most of Johnson's Senate career reads like a cross between an inspirational
lifetime TV movie and the arrest record of Harvey Weinstein.
If Johnson had already had a reputation as a bully, as Senate majority leader,
he was a thousand times worse.
He liked to force his secretaries to take notes while he urinated occasionally
showing them as Oregon and declaring.
Have you ever seen anything as big as this?
He scratched his private parts while speaking on the Senate floor threatens
those who stood in his way. Speaking of threats,
Senate Democrats soon learned to fear the Johnson treatments,
anyone who might break ranks was taken to one side there.
This John's of a man would trap them in a corner and repeatedly jotted them in
the chest with his finger,
threatening them with worse and worse fates until they finally cracked.
It was unpleasant. It was unacceptable. And it was also effective under Johnson.
The Senate Democrats became the United army and Johnson used this military
discipline to do undeniably great things where there's old benzo, Sam Raven.
Now speaker of the house Johnson pushed three bills.
Most Democrats would have previously never dreamed of voting for in 1950,
74 through Eisenhower's civil rights act.
The first civil rights legislation passed since reconstruction,
while Eisenhower was the driving force, passing the bill,
it would have been impossible without Johnson.
He was able to Sue the fears of his fellow southerners. When that didn't work,
he simply brow beat them into submission.
By 1960 Johnson's reputation in the Senate had grown so vast that he felt
confident enough to take part in the democratic primaries.
His only serious opponent was some Catholic green horn from Massachusetts.
You can always imagine Johnson giving a snot of laughter,
a Catholic leading the Democrats. This was going to be easy,
but of course Johnson had miscalculated.
John Fitzgerald Kennedy may have been both Catholic and young,
but he was anything but green JFK absolutely crushed the
primary Johnson whose plan had involved, not actively campaigning,
but simply hoovering up delegates. Thanks to his Senate.
Reputation was left eating the young man's dust come summer.
The telegenic Senator from Massachusetts was his party's candidates.
Almost an afterthought. JFK offered Johnson,
the VP place on his ticket to everyone's amazement Johnson said, yes.
It turns out to be a shrewd move on both of their parts,
despite his disappointments and not being top of the tickets.
Johnson campaigns like hell in the South,
his presence calm the Democrats skittish about Kennedy's Northern roots.
It made all the difference that November JFK won the presidency by the closest
margin since 1916, just edging out Nixon in the popular vote,
but a win is a win. And in January of 1961,
Johnson became vice president of the United States.
It was an exercise in bitter disappointments.
Although Kennedy gave Johnson important roles in the space program and military
policy, he kept the loud mouth texts him firmly out of his inner circle.
All of Johnson's insecurities came bubbling back up.
He envied Kennedy's slick Chon rage that his own Southern backgrounds meant that
he was looked down on. He wasn't wrong.
Bobby Kennedy openly regarded him as an uncouth hick,
but Johnson was also frustrated that his decades of congressional experience one
being put to use when JFK introduced a sweeping civil rights bill in 1963,
it stagnated precisely because Kennedy was unwilling to engage in the kind of
horse trading that Johnson was so adept at by that November Lyndon Johnson was
frustrated, disillusions and likely unsure what future he had left.
As he traveled to his home state with the presidency.
Might've wondered if he would ever fulfill his dream of being a great man of
history, of being remembered. Well, he needed needn't have worried.
Fate was about to throw him a helping hands in the bloodiest most tragic way
possible.
Lyndon Johnson's life changed forever at 12:30 PM on November the 22nd,
1963,
the vice president was riding just to cause behind as Kennedy was shot.
By the time Johnson reached the hospital,
the president had been pronounced dead barely two hours later, 2:38 PM.
Johnson took the oath of office on board air force,
one lady and Jacqueline Kennedy,
where his side below in the cargo holds of the remains of John Fitzgerald.
Kennedy waited to be flown back to Washington.
That same afternoon Johnson gave his first speeches presidents.
I will do my best. He told the shock nation. That is all I can do.
The days that followed were a maelstrom of confusion on November the 24th,
Jack Ruby killed Lee Harvey Oswald that same day Johnson appointed the Warren
commission to investigate behind the scenes. Two things were in turmoil.
Johnson chose not to replace any of JFK's cabinet.
It's giving the grieving nation a sense of continuity,
but there was still the weird,
uncomfortable drama of moving Jackie and the family out of the white house and
Johnson and lady bird in one adviser said that the site of JFK's rocking jab
being taken out just as Johnson's cowboy saddle was brought in,
made him comprehends the enormity of what had happens. Yes.
In the midst of the crisis,
Johnson's political cunning did not desert him Southern Democrats that stalled
Kennedy's civil rights bill to the point of killing it.
But Johnson realized that we're depending on the act on the memory of the slain
presidents, no one would dare oppose it in a heated debate.
During the early hours of November,
the 27th Jonathan's advisors begged him not to do it,
not to squander his Goodwill as JFK successor on rights for Negroes. Well,
what the hell is the presidency for Johnson replied? And that was that,
that same winds up Johnson reframed the civil rights act as Kennedy's legacy.
He began pushing it forward daring Congress to stand against him that spring
1964, the house passed a version of the act, even stronger than what JFK had.
Envisaged Southern Democrats were horrified and like Johnson staff.
It was election year, civil rights. We're a vote to loser.
Why not wait until after November,
but Johnson knew it was now or never over the next few months,
Johnson hammered away at the Senate rather than play it safe.
He chased down every Boston and made sure that he got his vote.
As a Southern Senator later said we could have beaten John Kennedy on civil
rights, but not Lyndon Johnson or more accurately,
not Lyndon Johnson who was cynically brilliantly using Kennedy's memory to get
what he wanted. I'd lost following a near record,
83 day filibuster by southerners.
The bill cleared the Senate on July the second, 1964,
Lyndon B Johnson sat down in front of an audience,
including luminaries like Martin Luther King and signs.
The civil rights act into law.
The most significant piece of legislation passed in post-war America.
The civil rights act ended Jim Crow,
segregation and the rights of employers to discriminate on grounds of race while
racism would still, in fact, many parts of us society,
it was a massive step in the right direction.
Basically that day Johnson remarks to an eight. It is an important game,
but I think we just delivered the South to the Republican party for a long time
to come yet.
He still signs the bill despite knowing it would huddle his potty display to
knowing it would cost him reelection. That right there. That is why,
despite all the bullying, all the nastiness,
there are still people who respect the 36th president.
[Inaudible].
In the ends.
The civil rights act didn't have Johnson's re-election Johnson at all.
There aren't ligans made the mistake of nominating Barry Goldwater.
A guy is so right-wing the Democrats easily painted him as a trigger.
Happy extremist that November Johnson won the presidency with
61% of the popular vote.
Still the highest margin in history Johnson took his landslide as a
mandate to transform the country. He declared a war on poverty,
increased welfare, established Medicaid,
and Medicare began the headstart program in schools appointed the first African
Americans to both the U S cabinet and the Supreme court.
He built new homes and granted huge tracks of wilderness, federal protection.
As far as Johnson was concerned,
he was picking up where the new deal left off creating,
which he called the great society.
Some of it like head start is still widely used today. Yeah.
While it would be social programs that built his legacy in his era,
Johnson would be known for two things, war and race relations.
And let's start with race relations. Just like the civil rights act.
A whole bunch of Southern States were still doing what they could to keep
nonwhite people from participating in democracy on a state level.
This often played out with ridiculous voter registration laws,
which used the fig leaf of literacy tests to disenfranchise millions of
black Americans.
So Johnson did what Johnson did best using his gigantic frame and uncouth
personality as a weapon. He bullied,
pressured and brow beat Congress into passing the 1965 voting rights act
as one slightly hyperbolic source it.
Abraham Lincoln struck off the chains of black Americans.
It was Johnson who led them into the voting booths. Of course,
this telling ignores all the black activists on the ground,
doing the hardest work of all and getting the bruises to show for it.
Bruises because Johnson's presidency was plagued by race rots over for
long hot summers from 1965 to 1968.
Race rights exploded everywhere from LA to Ohio,
to Washington DC.
When Johnson set up the national advisory commission on civil disorders,
they returned with a stark warning. Thanks to decades of inequality.
America was in danger of dividing into two societies,
one white and one black for the pro civil rights Johnson.
This was a polling news, but if racial tensions were running high in the cities,
things were even worse abroad. After swearing on the campaign trail,
not to increase the U S presence in Vietnam.
Johnson opened his first full term with a massive influx of soldiers and bombing
raids. By 1968,
over half a million us servicemen would be in Vietnam in a conflict that would
eventually claim over 58,000 American lives.
And to millions of Vietnamese as the war grew,
Johnson's popularity dropped to eventually plummeting to 40% everywhere.
He went, the president would encounter protesters chanting, Hey, Hey LBJ,
how many kids did you kill today? But while by 1968,
the honeymoon period was definitely over Johnson.
Still wasn't done constitutionally.
He had a right to run for another full time and why not? He was unpopular,
but no more so than Harry Truman had been winded pulled off his surprise,
1948 win, but Johnson,
wasn't going to have a chance to put his legendary campaign skills to the test.
As 1968 dawned, something was about to happen.
That would make his chances of another term sync from unlikely to utterly
impossible
In terms of losing the battle. But winning the propaganda war,
it's hard to think of a more successful campaign than the Tet offensive starting
in January, 1968, the Viet Cong engaged in a whirlwind of chemicals,
the attacks bringing carnage in their week militarily. It was useless.
One estimate puts the North Vietnamese casualties as high as a hundred
thousands, but in terms of optics, Oh boy,
was it ever a winner course on the back foot?
The Johnson white house was left unable to explain the sudden increase in
Americans coming home in body bags and its failure to win a war.
It had said it was almost over that's. Then a month later,
the democratic primary has got underwear and New Hampshire outside challenger,
Eugene McCarthy management at 41% of the vote,
a huge blow to any sitting president by now.
Johnson could barely leave the white house without getting booed or hackles.
Ben Bobby Kennedy announced that he would be entering the race and Johnson
realized that the game was over.
He could have maybe bounced back Truman stall from an unpopular war in 1967
bits. After the Tet offensive, he was toast on March the 31st,
1968. Lyndon B Johnson made a surprise TV announcements,
as well as instructing the military to begin peace talks with North Vietnam.
He declared that he would not seek a second time as president any elation
Democrats felt at Johnson's exit was quickly countered by a series of disasters.
Just days later, Martin Luther King Jr was assassinated in Memphis,
sparking a fresh wave of rotting. Two months off to that.
Bobby Kennedy was shot dead in California.
When the democratic convention finally met in August massive rots and battles
with police all contributed to the feeling of a country's living out of control.
Come November.
The electorate voted for the man who promised law and order Richard Nixon,
Lyndon Johnson,
left office under a cloud of abysmal approval ratings and a recent Republican
landslide. He retired back to his ranch in Texas, but it wasn't a long life.
Post-presidency on January the 22nd, 1973,
Lyndon Johnson died of a heart attack. It was 64 today.
The Lyndon Johnson legacy is a complicated one.
While the similarly unpopular Truman would be reassessed as one of America's
greatest presidents opinion on Johnson still goes up and down like some sort of
demented yo-yo. On the one hand, he was a Prize-winning,
a guy who would slip his hand up a secretary skirt.
He would reduce his staff is to tears and he wasn't afraid of using physical
violence. On the other hand,
he genuinely did care about America's racial minorities in the alternative
universe, where at JFK survives Dallas,
you have a weaker civil rights acts and no voting rights act,
or the legacy of Johnson then is a mixed one,
both truly great and truly awful, depending on which part you're looking at,
but then you couldn't have one without the other. It was Johnson's bad.
Sight is terrible ego.
This drove him to the top that made him desperate to be remembered yet.
It was only thanks to that dark drive that he was eventually able to end Jim
Crow for all this myriad faults.
Lyndon Johnson ends up being that rare beast,
a demonstrably bad man who devoted his life to doing good.
His legacy may be a complex one, but without him,
America would undoubtedly be a worse place than it is today.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe a brand new video several times a week.
Thank you for watching.